Welcome to the summary of the first 50 days.
Tusk governments
Although the new government has been in power for less than two months,
that he did so much
that it is worth summarizing
and I would start with the loan cancellation 2%
we did not receive 0% credit as tusk promised
but instead of credit for it
which worked well
It was very popular and was discontinued.
And as the new coalition in the election campaign said
that it will introduce a voluntary zus for entrepreneurs
it so introduced voluntary zus but for 1 month
All the other months have been
increased by £250 per month
Tusk said
that will take here quotes simple and concrete actions
so that the fuel was worth 5 and 19 cents
So such actions
started IP fuel surcharge increase OD 13%
Despite our many years
Acute policy
Reception of illegal immigrants
New Government in the European Parliament
He agreed to accept them.
ym
And here is a small digression to people who think
that we now have free tvp media
it in free media tvp
While the ruling coalition
They agreed to accept immigrants.
Maybe in the future it will be necessary to accept
Immigrants but a maximum of 30,000
it is not a maximum of 30,000 but a minimum of 30,000
and not maybe just for sure
and the EU is preparing an equalization package for us
So all countries
who have not yet accepted refugees
They will have to accept more.
So we're talking about half a million refugees.
The new government said
that he will finally restore the rule of law in Poland
So he started with breaking the law
Violation of the law is the seizure of illegal media
Just like politicians
They spoke
that yy the correct document
Public media will come in the future.
This document did not come at all.
because the national court register has recognised
that the new authorities will not be entered in the register
Because they were chosen by
an authority not authorized to do so
Another violation of the law
The State Prosecutor's Office in
The illegal way
Minister of Justice Bodnar
announced a new national prosecutor's office
to cancel the previous
Signature of the President is required
President Dudes
did not receive any documents for signature
and so on
The Justice Department does what it wants.
Another great step
to yy
Reduction in defence spending
from PLN 150 billion to PLN 118 billion
and remind
that the new governments were very critical of law and justice
for increasing the subordinate deficit
This budget deficit
increased by PLN 20 billion
Reduced defense spending
and something that moves me the most
blocking strategic investments for Poland
such as cpk
Back in the election campaign,
Tusk said
that it is a sick pisowski
yy senseless idea
yy now stated
that despite this
that design work is already underway on this yy port
Tusk stated
Another audit needs to be conducted
whether it makes sense to continue the project
Another blocked investment is a port with blues
which is incredibly competitive for ports
Hamburg and especially Germany oppose
Expansion of this port
and paulina henningroska
The Environment Minister stated
This place is perfect for another national park.
which will effectively prevent the expansion of the port
I will add more selective use
Rights of the New Government
because when the Emergency Audit Chamber decides
that mini that mustache and stone
They are still members
The new government says it is unconstitutional.
but when the same chamber rules on the validity of the election
There are no constitutional issues
but Tusk voters are certainly satisfied
because now you can buy
Day After pill No prescription
A 16-year-old will not be able to buy electricity.
but tablet ym day After As most
of good things
They also introduced increases for teachers.
while we hear all the time about mustache and kamiński
It's all happening behind our backs
also summarizing
for the new government
The goal is to destroy everything.
Poland blocking the Polish economy
they are doing very well